[Musik]
hey leben heute gibt es ein rezept was
extrem stark angefragt wurde den letzten
zwei bis zweieinhalb jahren und zwar
machen wir köstliches ziemlich das sind
typische saison regel die gibt es in der
türkei zum beispiel alle fünf meter auf
der straße so ganz klassisch kulturelle
ich liebe das
und in deutschland gibt sie mittlerweile
natürlich auch und nicht nur die türken
lieben das sondern einfach jeder was sie
mir ist einfach lecker zu schwarzem tee
oder einfach mal so oder zum frühstück
durchgeschnitten und belegt warum wir
das ganze machen hat auch einen grund
wir fliegen nach istanbul
beziehungsweise jetzt wo ihr dieses
videos sind wir gerade in istanbul und
machen mit 100 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit richtig coole story
is daher müsst je nachdem er das video
guckt habt uns unbedingt drüben auf
instagram folgen also einmal mir und
natürlich auch dem hammer wenn ich
gerade mal nicht kann auch der nachweis
gerne auf jeden fall verlinkt ich euch
unsere instagram accounts nochmal in die
video beschreibung genau so wie alle
zutaten die ich hier benutze und ich
lege jetzt direkt los mit dem teig
tschäppäts hier mail ich kann euch
direkt färbt den tipp geben etwas mehl
mal wie das mache ich oft so an die
seite legen also nicht alles da
reingeben da habe ich jetzt so eine
kleine mulde und ihr könnt das rezept
mit trockenhefe und mit frischhefe
machen auf instagram habe ich gerade
eine umfrage gestartet was er lieber
möge die meisten sagen die noch frische
hefe daher mache ich jetzt auch mit
frischer häufig gibt es hier die hälfte
meines lauwarmem wasser in die mulde
brösel da die frische hefe hinein und
gibt da auch noch ein bisschen zucker
dazu und dann las ich dass zugedeckt so
ungefähr acht bis zehn minuten stehen
[Musik]
jetzt konnte die hefe vorab schon mal
ein bisschen arbeiten und jetzt gebe ich
die schüsse an meine neue küchenmaschine
ich bin noch so ein bisschen beschwerden
weil die mattschwarze nagelneu ist die
die mir auf instagram folgen die haben
den vorteil und wissen das schon
ansonsten schreibe ich euch auch noch
mal wieder zu in die infobox
ihr könnt natürlich auch mit der hand
machen gleich werde ich auch mit der
hand auf jeden fall weiter kneten
aber ich gebe jetzt also jetzt erst salz
dazu weil salz und frische hefe
vertragen sich nicht so gut und faultier
trockenhefe benutzen dann könnt ihr
alles vorab schon menschen dann müsste
ja dann habt ihr diese wartezeit auch
nicht schreibe ich euch dann auch ganz
genau in die video beschreibung spricht
infobox und ich fange ich an ganz um zu
kneten dem knethaken und gibt dann nach
und nach so viel mehl dazu dass ich dass
man hier so einen festen teig erhält und
dann mit den händen weiter kneten
[Musik]
so die hilfe kommt jetzt vorab schon ein
bisschen arbeiten und anschließend gibt
ihr das restliche wasser dazu ich bin
uns heute übrigens um eine
küchenmaschine mit dem knethaken gibt es
seit anschließend noch mit dazu und nach
und nach das restliche mehl und da bitte
aufpassen also ihr werdet gleich auf
jeden fall mit den händen weiter kneten
man bekommt ja auch so ein richtiges
gefühl dafür aber nicht zu viel mehr ein
weil sonst ist der teig zu hart so und
jetzt nämlich den teig auf eine
arbeitsfläche und knete wie gesagt mit
bemehlten händen weiter und euch ist
bestimmt schon merklich maschine
ausgefallen
das ist die nagelneue weltkrieges in
mattschwarz ich habe schon auf instagram
erzählt das ist die exklusiv nur bei uns
in dieser farbe gibt und ich habe schon
megafon geschwärmt daher verlinke ich
euch sie einfach mal in die infobox dann
könnt ihr euch einen eigenen eindruck
davon machen so und wie gesagt aber
darauf dass der tag wirklich nicht zu
fest ist der also er braucht diesen
schmalen grat zwischen gerade noch
klebend und fest und wenn ihr den
erreicht dann werden eure stimme zu
wunderbar
[Musik]
nach dem kneten wird der teig zu einer
kugel gerollt und von unten und oben mit
mehl ausgestoppt in der schüssel so
gedeckt hohen gelassen für circa 45
minuten ganz wichtig an einem warmen ort
und dann habt ihr nach 45 minuten das
ergebnis der teig ist schön aufgegangen
und ich gebe den jetzt auf meine
bemehlten arbeitsfläche und krete dir
nochmal ganz kurz durch und anschließend
teile ist ihm in ungefähr 65 gramm dicke
teiglinge
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt neun kügelchen bzw 19
rausbekommen ziemlich mit einigen
teiglingen und er werde den ganz dünnen
zu einem dünnen strang ausgemacht dass
auf jeden fall auf der bemehlten
arbeitsfläche ganz langsam von innen
nach außen und der streng ist als extra
abgemessen der eso circa 78 bis 80 cm
lang und habt ihr so eine vorstellung
davon und dann zeige ich euch gleich
wieso 1 mit entsteht
jetzt schnappt ihr euch den langen
strang und verbindet die zwei endstücke
und hier habt da am besten so einen
kleinen finger dazwischen ich sage euch
gleich noch warum nicht einmal zwiebeln
und jetzt habt ihr hier den finger
dazwischen gehabt deshalb packt er das
endstück einmal hier ganz grob rein und
dann könnt ihr das noch so ein bisschen
verschönern aber im grunde ist das jetzt
eure perfektes image form so
[Musik]
jetzt verrühren wir trauben sirup wasser
und mehl in einer tiefen schüssel oder
in einem tiefen teller miteinander und
das ist ganz wichtig denn das ist unsere
typische tränke ohne traum sirup
funktioniert dieses rezept nicht das ist
ganz ganz wichtig für diesen typischen
geschmack und jetzt nehmen wir uns
einmal ein teiglingen so und geben das
direkt einmal hier in dieses traum zero
wasser gemisch kurz ein drucken nur ganz
kurz und dann hier einmal in sesam
wälzen von beiden seiten so wie sie ist
das genau dann einfach hier auf das
backblech und dann kann man hier noch
mal fehlt zum beispiel ein bisschen was
hauptsache ist es alles bedeckt
[Musik]
ich gebe jetzt immer dreister aufs blech
weil die halt so ein bisschen platz
brauchen die werden auch minimal
aufgehen aber so haben sie einfach
ausreichend viel platz das heißt ich
kriege drei bleche rauslassen jetzt noch
mal zehn minuten entspannen einfach dass
die nicht nach dem kneten direkt in den
backofen kommt und jetzt kommt die
backzeit ganz ganz wichtig der ofen muss
vorgeheizt seien auf 220 grad ober und
unterhitze und dann packen wir das image
für neun bis zehn minuten
ihr müsst einfach mal schauen ob sie die
gewünschte farbe erreichten sie dürfen
nicht zu hart sein also schaut gerne mal
nach neuneinhalb minuten rein und dann
zeige ich euch gleich das ergebnis
[Musik]
sollte perfektes team wird muss außen
richtig schön knackig und innen soft
sein
das machen wir mal die geräusche probe
genauso also wirklich außen total kross
und innen superweiche ja wir können uns
den jetzt also ich finde sie so wirklich
perfekt es gibt echt geteilte meinungen
einige mögen die richtigen dick und
andere eben etwas dünner ich bin so team
etwas dünner aber ihr könnt natürlich
ausrollen wie ihr möchtet der teig ist
auf jeden fall jetzt ein grundrezept für
euch sie mit tag mache ich immer gerne
ohne milch oder joghurt oder ähnliches
weil ich eben genau diese weiche
konsistenz haben möchte und außen eben
schön kross und ansonsten ja noch mal
der hinweis die genauen mengenangaben
unten in der video beschreibung und wir
sind kein eben gerade in istanbul wo ich
das erzählt und lasst uns uns bestimmt
kulinarisch total gut gehen lassen
gerade einzieht und ich lass euch jetzt
wünsch euch noch einen wunderschönen tag
abonniert main kanal einfach passt ja
auch nichts mehr
dann sehen wir uns im nächsten mal
charme soll jetzt aber danke dass sie
mit den zurück ins tor
[Musik]